[Música]
muitos me perguntam como eu descobri que
eu queria ser professor e ser diretor
e eu respondo que não descobrir que tudo
foi por acaso mas desde o primeiro dia
que eu comecei a ser professor sentir
que não queria deixar de ser professor e
desde o primeiro dia que eu comecei a
ser diretor sentir que eu queria ser
diretor
e tudo foi por acaso eu estava
credenciado para pra dar aulas e
precisava sobreviver e fui diretor por
influência da minha falecida mulher
arlete ter sólida e durante o meu
percurso
eu vi e vivi várias situações em que os
meus alunos se mostraram extremamente
inteligentes e competentes
em uma das escolas que eu dei aula um
dia a diretora me chamou até sua sala e
disse braz
eu gostaria que você preparasse um dia
de atividades com os alunos que eu vou
convidar os pais que eu vou convidar
autoridades e eu todo orgulhoso aceitei
de pronto e no dia o princial principal
atividade seria um debate em que os
alunos representavam os políticos da
época tinha também alunos representando
repórteres apresentador
e do meu lado tinha uma aluna viviane
representando a marília gabriela e eu
todo orgulhoso no comando do debate
coordenando o debate dando a palavra
para todos
de repente me deu um branco e eu não
sabia nem onde eu estava eu fiquei
paralisado ea viviane menina de 5ª série
me conduziu e dizia de forma sutil
tudo o que eu tinha que fazer e esta foi
uma das sensações mais agradáveis que eu
senti na minha vida
numa outra escola eu tinha um aluno
chamado nels e o nelson foi o primeiro
aluno que eu duvidei da inteligência
eu falava não o nelsinho não tem jeito
mesmo
ele não tem inteligência e aí fui fazer
um curso de psicodrama pedagógico
introduzir algumas técnicas nas minhas
aulas e uma das atividades eram
representações e o nelso começou a se
destacar nesta representações que
começou a ser disputado pelos seus
colegas
todo mundo queria ser do grupo do nels
então eu conto esses dois casos para
dizer que criança aluno é um ser
extremamente competente competente em
novembro de 1995
cheguei na escola presidente campos
salles pra ser o seu diretor
encontrei uma escola muito difícil ea
violência era o maior problema tinha de
cinco a seis brigas diárias de alunos e
em heliópolis
das chacinas do toque de recolher e o
que é que eu tinha para enfrentar essa
situação
eu tinha duas coisas primeiro a certeza
de que a criança é um ser capaz e
segundo duas idéias
tudo passa pela educação ea escola tem
que ser um centro de liderança na
comunidade onde está inserida
com isto eu sair a campo para articular
os segmentos da comunidade escolar e
incluir aí as lideranças comunitárias
disso resultou uma forte integração
escola comunidade
mas o maior problema continuava que era
as práticas tradicionais dentro da sala
de aula e num dia de muita sorte
apareceu na minha sala
três professoras
uma dela de nome mara e falou braz lá em
portugal tem uma escola conhecida como
escola da ponte
lá o aluno é visto e respeitado como um
ser completo como um ser integral como
um ser que é capaz de se organizar
individual e coletivamente para aprender
e viver alguns meses depois eu fui fazer
um curso de educação comunitária em meu
trabalho de conclusão de curso foi a
implementação de uma metodologia de
ensino com base nos princípios da escola
da ponte logo que foi aprovado o projeto
pelo conselho de escola
nós retiramos várias paredes internas da
escola
no lugar de 12 salas de aula
construímos quatro grandes salões e foi
colocado neste momento um desafio para
os professores e os alunos eles não
tinham alternativa a única alternativa
seria trabalhar em equipe porque dentro
do salão fica no mínimo três professores
e 80 alunos em média
dividido em grupos de quatro alunos e o
que articula tudo aluno aluno professor
professor professores e os alunos é um
roteiro de estudo que os professores
elaboram com antecedência
esse roteiro vai pra dentro do salão é
entregue para os grupos ea proposta é
que os alunos trabalhem de forma
autônoma
mas quando se tem uma dúvida
o aluno levanta a mão deles e um dos
três professores vai até o grupo não pra
explicar ou dar a resposta mas pra
oferecer recursos para que os alunos
descubra a resposta por si mesmos e vai
a equipe de televisão jornalista fazer
matéria na escola e chega no final fazem
sempre uma pergunta fatídica e o ideb
qual é a nota do ideb o ideb é uma
avaliação externa que é feita de dois em
dois anos
e eu respondo desde quando começou o
projeto desde quando começou a fazer
essa prova
a gente tem crescido lenta e
gradualmente a nota é ainda muito baixa
mas eu respondo
bem e debby no med autonomia no med
responsabilidade no med solidariedade e
estes são os princípios da escola então
na escola presidente campos salles
o professor é aquele que oferece
recursos e mais recursos para que o
aluno aprenda com tudo e com todos em
todos os lugares e sempre e nós já temos
a certeza que lá está nascendo um novo
aluno um novo professor uma nova escola
e com ela o bairro educador de
heliópolis
abaixo a padronização e viva a
criatividade em todas as escolas do
mundo
[Aplausos]